everybody
to jerry not everybody can pull off 42
years without getting fired jerry you
don't have to work so hard you're
retiring i don't have to be these are
your golden years
how's my account two percent gains you
just gotta be more aggressive i could
double your money in seven point two
seven years
literally the only time i was gonna get
to use that today
jerry you're gonna have to tell me
what's going on i was always good with
math codes puzzles you name it but i
just feel like i never got to be a part
of the world
i found this flaw there's a loophole
that the lottery didn't see it's right
here in the map i don't know what this
says it looks like the numbers are crazy
man drew in a cell well i cannot believe
you are my accountant
i'm playing the lottery and i won 15 000
why didn't you just tell me we barely
have enough money to retire on this is
no time to risk it
yes it is what
can i help you we'd like to buy 8 000
windfall tickets
i'm gonna help you first
three hundred and twelve thousand
now we want to start a corporation we'll
split the profits with the whole town
[Music]
the more we bet the better the odds
let's do it
there's another group these kids figured
it out the payout should have been
bigger we're really hurting each other
by playing at the same time i just need
you out of the game we're not done do
you know what the dark web is jerry
because it's gonna be the only place to
buy your life back when i'm done selling
it to countries that you can't even
pronounce
i'm gonna do it to everyone in your
group
the lottery suspended our license we're
betting half a million go big or go home
[Music]
really does feel like we're robbing a
bank nah this is going to be more fun
we are betting 40 000 on windfall
tickets
are you guys drug dealers we're
professional lottery players that isn't
a thing it is now
[Music]
you